okay our friend Tom Hartman from the
Thom Hartmann program has a really
interesting article that he's written
about Donald Trump's Attorney General
William bar and how his role with regard
to the molar probe is very similar to
his role in other historical events
related to possible wrong wrongdoing by
presidents of the United States to set
it up
William Bar was hired for a specific
reason by Donald Trump okay Donald Trump
had a plan which included the interim
installation of Matthew Whitaker to give
Donald from time to find the right
person to put in as Attorney General who
would be beneficial in terms of their
worldview to Donald Trump in the context
of the Moller probe okay that person was
William Barr William Barr said more than
a year ago that the president a
president cannot be indicted for
obstruction so very clearly this is the
guy that Donald Trump wanted and that's
the reason why Donald Trump wanted him
to be attorney general what we're now
learning is that William Barr actually
has a long track record of covering up
crimes and he's really good at it and we
learned this thanks to a great article
from Tom Hartman who wrote yesterday
this piece called Trump's attorney
general bill Barr has a history of
cover-ups and he just struck again
William Bar was Attorney General back in
1992 and he was known at the time in
some circles not as the Attorney General
but as the cover-up general that's what
William Safire called him at the time he
buried evidence of George HW Bush's
involvement in Iraq gate he buried
evidence related to iran-contra he
resisted the appointment of special
counsels multiple times successfully to
the point that his name was even being
mentioned as someone who is not just
involved in covering it up but was so
potentially corrupt that William Barr
maybe should even be investigated for
his involvement in those cover-ups and
people often talk about the founding
fathers and the intentions of the
founding fathers and were actually
working on a long-form piece about that
a president that
cannot be indicted period would not be
the type of immune president that the
founding fathers would have wanted when
they framed the system of law and
constitution of the United States of
America a president who can appoint
their Attorney General to declare
whether they are innocent or potentially
guilty of crimes including obstruction
that's not the type of presidential
immunity that the founding fathers would
have wanted when they established how
the United States would function and so
Barr has simply struck again
Barr has now cherry-picked a summary of
a summary of Robert molars investigation
we all knew when William Barr was
selected by Donald Trump exactly why he
had been selected and it worked I mean
we don't even you know people are some
people are reacting not all but some
people are reacting in the email to me
as if it's this big shock how this thing
all went down you have Trump managing
the investigation the way he did and
then in comes Barr and everything goes
down and now all of a sudden were
shocked that it's up to Barr to decide
whether Trump obstructed justice and lo
and behold he decided that he didn't
after putting out a very political and
carefully worded four-page summary of a
summary why are you shocked this is
exactly the job that William Barr was
hired to do by President Donald Trump
and he did it and the really important
question that Tom Hartman asks in this
article about William Barr uh and I'll
read from it he says quote the question
this time is whether Congress will be as
compliant as they were in 1993 and
simply let it all go both Trump and
senior Republican leadership are get are
already calling for a repeat of 1993
what remains to be seen is if the press
and Democratic leadership will go along
like they did back then tomorrow I am
going to tell you and and really focus
in on the atrocious atrocious media job
that was done reacting to William bars
for
summary and I think that Donald Trump is
exactly right it remains to be seen if
the press is going to allow the exact
same thing to happen now with Donald
Trump and William Barr and the molar
investigation as what happened back in
1993 with George HW Bush if the first 48
hours of reaction of course from
conservative media but also from plain
old centrist corporate media also from
some enclaves of leftist media it has
been disgusting
the reaction we have seen from media
outlets of all kinds we're going to talk
about it tomorrow and if things don't
change with media coverage of this
report and if we don't start getting
some actual down-to-earth analyses of
what the report does mean and doesn't
mean I'm at least trying to do it but I
can't do it alone
this is going to go exactly the same way
as it did in 1993 one of today's
sponsors is minds.com
minds is an open source social network
platform it's kind of like YouTube
Facebook and Twitter all in one package
except that the goal of minds is to help
create a free and open Internet where
privacy and free speech are the top
priority and to make sure that content
creators are fairly compensated for
their efforts Minds doesn't track you
like a lot of other social networks do
and users on minds can earn minds tokens
for interacting with the site such as
when you like dislike or share content
or when you create content yourself by
uploading a photo or video or writing a
blog post then your minds tokens can be
used to boost your content on the site
so that more people will see it
mine's even offers a feature kind of
like patreon where your fans can unlock
your premium content by sending you
minds tokens everything is encrypted for
example minds can't read your private
messages on the platform and like I
mentioned everything is open source
meaning that in the interest of
transparency you can actually see the
code that fuels the site which is
definitely not something that lots of
other social and content sharing
platforms
can say minds sees a lot of issues with
today's most popular social media
platforms especially when it comes to
free speech privacy transparency and
compensating content creators and those
are the problems that they're trying to
solve I encourage you to go check it out
at minds.com there's also a mobile app
and you can actually follow the david
pakman show on mines at minds.com slash
david pakman show I've also put a link
right underneath this video